[Applause]
[Music]
question party is very simple you guys
in the audience are gonna ask me and
tara questions and we are going to
answer them okay who has a question
green shirt guy my question is and i
will share this with my two birthday
twins today is my birthday and i was
wondering if tarek featuring amber would
sing a little happy birthday to us
oh yeah
i mean i i feel like we we could however
oh the version of happy birthday we sing
probably can't be aired cause we don't
do happy birthday like we're black
so we have to make it up we we will have
to make it up okay okay okay all right
what's your name anthony anthony and um
quint and madison and madison
matt manson madsen
madsen quint and anthony i've already
forgotten matson quit an answer
all right matson
clint and anthony and she hams
oh man come on
everybody don't snap along if you're
gonna be our feet that's right
yeah um it's somebody's birthday oh
can't you see
he's too tall his name is anthony
that's all right a brief birthday stint
him and his loyal
name quit yeah
the last name i had son or what was that
last name i think it was massive and
that's right we hope that today these
three folks have a happy birthday
birthday
is that all right is that good
you guys that's all the time we have for
question party this was great should we
do this again some other time
[Applause]
you